human history is the story of one
terrible catastrophe after another
I for once would love to wake up
magically in a better world
[Music]
I think the world's going to get better
people get their energy from the Sun
humans have set foot on Mars
cancer has been defeated
and yet for every question answered
another one appears
I'll go to [__] at the end of the
century we'll be dead we'll have to miss
it but we'll be smiling in gold-plated
coffee
it's not the life that I envisioned it
to be
whose house is on fire is incredibly
easy to negotiate
we cannot give up and go home
for one simple reason
we already are home this is our only
home
I think it helps to look at climate
change like a bear
the whole planet's been wrestling with
the bear for decades
so far the Bear's been kicking our ass
what if we were able to develop
technology that would allow us to
survive maybe even Thrive you don't know
what's going to happen
it won't go the way you want
it never does
I remember being happy so what about now
are you happy now
are we bad people
stop being angry about the past the
future is now
Miami is dangerous your mother's moving
with her sister in Chicago thought you
hated your sister it's too hot out
to hate people these days Marshall
[Music]